Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Willkommen beim neuen Jahr.
Willkommen.
Wir haben uns natürlich schon gleich 0 Uhr 1 ein gutes neues Jahr gewünscht, aber an dieser Stelle auch nochmal für alle gutes neues Jahr.
Ein gutes neues Jahr, das Ereignisreich beginnt.
Und Komplex auch.
Um das noch abzubilden, wir sprachen noch an Silvestern und wir waren erst gemeinsam in Europa, in Wiesbaden und waren dann in unserer geliebten Bar in Frankfurt darüber, dass es diesen Einbruch gab in Gelsenkirchen in der Bank und du hast dann gesagt, dass es das Thema, das in den nächsten Wochen dominierend sein wird. Was du natürlich nicht ahnen konntest, ist, dass etwa 20 andere Dinge danach geschehen, die auch einen enormen Ereignis-Charakter haben, sodass Gelsenkirchen immer noch wichtig ist, aber natürlich schon überdeckt wird oder zumindest Konkurrenz bekommt durch andere Ereignisse.
Ja, aber die Themen haben ja alle etwas gemeinsam. In Gelsenkirchen wird das Ding ausgeraubt und man weiß nicht, ob es 30 oder 300 Millionen waren, wie auch immer. Und man stellt fest, in den AGBs steht etwas, aber die Anwälte sagen, ne, wenn da 10.000 Euro drinsteht, ist das eine überraschende Klausel. Da muss die Bank erst mal nachweisen, dass das gerechtfertigt ist. Plus, welche Verantwortung hat die Bank, um das zu verhindern, dass das passiert? Also relativ viele Sachen, wo man sich denkt, ich dachte, es sind in den Texten geregelt, aber anscheinend doch nicht.
Ja, mir war ja auch gar nicht klar, ich habe kein Schließfach, dass das Schließfach dann nur bis 10.000 Euro versichert ist. Denn da frage ich mich, bei 10.000 Euro kann man es ja fast in den Nachttisch legen, dann brauche ich ja kein Schließfach.
Genau, für 10.000 Euro brauche ich ja gar kein Schließfach.
Es sei denn, ich habe jetzt ein paar Dokumente oder alte Liebesbriefe, die ich gerne sicher aufbewahren will, dann kann man das dort tun. Aber zu sagen, ich lege da fünf Rolex-Uren rein, wäre dann eher dumm.
Genau, und dann stellt sich ja die Frage, was ist ein Schließfach der Sparkasse? Ist das nicht stellvertretend für den Staat? Wenn auch nicht faktisch, dann zumindest in der Gefühlslage. Das ist also noch zu klären. Jetzt haben wir eine neue Themenlage gehabt, die natürlich auch drastisch ist, Stromausfall in Berlin. Interessant ist schon, dass sich so langsam kommunalpolitische Sachen hochspielen. Also sie werden irgendwie so relevanter. Manduro ist so ein Ausnahmefall, aber schon ist man wieder in Minnesota, wo Eis jetzt Leute auf offener Straße erschießt. Von daher wird dieses Jahr durchaus komplex, aber nicht wegen Maduro. Das ist das Einzige, was nicht komplex ist.
Und alle kennen jetzt den Bürgermeister von Berlin. Das war auch vorher nicht der Fall. Und man fragt sich, warum wir Tennis spielen. Dass es jetzt die Frage an ihn gestellt wird, ist natürlich der Wunsch da, jetzt so eine Verantwortung herzustellen oder auch eine nicht vorhandene Macht dann in dem Moment. Das sind bestimmt für die Boulevardpresse tolle Geschichten, aber ich glaube, dass es am Ende sehr weit weggeht von dem, was jetzt eigentlich interessant ist, nämlich dass tatsächlich so eine Vulnerabilität, um diesen Begriff mal zu nennen, vorhanden ist, dass also so schnell so viel passieren kann von einer offenbar kleinen terroristischen Gruppe.
Sofern es überhaupt Terrorismus war, niemand hat von dieser Vulkan-Gruppe je gehört.
Ich hatte das auch nie gehört, ja.
Sie kommt von diesem isländischen Vulkan, weil damals die Flugzeuge nicht flogen und irgendwas hat mit dieser Zeit zu tun, keine Ahnung. Also ja, Linksterrorismus, okay. Ich habe mich jetzt die letzten Wochen durch Bezüge, über die ich später nochmal rede, sehr viel mit Linksextremismus im Sinne von Widerstand gegen LS beschäftigt. Also man liest von Tucholski, Osijetski und so weiter. Und dann heißt plötzlich, das sind Linksterroristen. Und offenbar denkt gar keiner mehr nach, was das eigentlich bedeuten sollte überhaupt. Da taucht dieser Text auf, alle Fragen, die so, was hat es damit auf sich? Das Tennisspiel von Kai Wegner finde ich wahnsinnig interessant. Denn es erinnert ja an Anne Spiegel, die also in den Urlaub fährt und deswegen ihren Job verliert als Familienbundesministerin.
Ja, also während der Ahrtal-Katastrophe fährt sie in den Urlaub, sagt dann, dass sie an Konferenzen teilgenommen hat, stellt sich nachher heraus, nee, sie hat auch an vielen dieser Online-Konferenzen nicht teilgenommen. Hier geht es jetzt um einen Mittag oder Nachmittag, den Kai Wegner nicht mit Krisenmanagement, sondern mit Tennisspiel, ja, verschwendet hat. Es ist schon erstaunlich, dass man in der Situation auf die Idee kommt, Tennis zu spielen. Also ich würde auch sagen, da muss irgendwas ein bisschen schieflaufen in der Regierungskompetenz.
Wir lesen heute ein Buch, in der steht drin, dass in Amerika gewählte Politiker pro Tag vier Stunden mit ihren Spendern verbringen, im direkten Austausch. Die wichtige Frage ist also, mit wem war Kai Wegner Tennisspiel, nicht, ob er Tennisspiel war und warum konnte er diesen Termin nicht absagen? So, das ist das eine. Das andere ist, in diesem Buch wird auch abgehandelt, dass es jetzt gerade das erste Mal in Amerika lukrativer ist, bei einer Bank zu arbeiten, als sie zu besitzen. Es wird quasi das ganze Geld für, weil die Leute plötzlich Milliarden verdienen müssen, rausgeben an Leute, die es wirklich können. Jetzt können wir diese Welt mal aufteilen in Leute, die es können und Leute, die so als Zuschauer daneben stehen. Es fällt Strom in Berlin aus. Alle sind noch so in Weihnachts-Neujahrsstimmung, sind ein bisschen alarmiert. Und es geht ein Hilferuf an alle Behörden, die damit zu tun haben. Und wirklich jeder Feuerwehrmann rückt aus. Die Polizei steht an jeder Straßenecke. Alle sind zusammengezogen. Was braucht man in diesem Moment nicht in diesem Szenario? Ein ganz fleißigen Bürgermeister, der auch die ganze Zeit denkt, er kann da noch was mitmachen.
Das glaube ich nicht. Nein, der Bürgermeister muss ja ein Riesenmanagement mitgestalten. Also er ist ja nicht nur repräsentativ. Aber ich bin da ja auch bei Anne Spiegel ganz rigoros. Wenn man den Job hat, muss man einfach zur Stelle sein. Was ich nicht erwarte, ist, dass man irgendwo mit Gummistiefeln rumläuft oder dass man sonst irgendwas macht mit der Taschenlampe, dann ist die Häuser. Was ist die Stelle? Man ist im Büro und arbeitet. Also es wird in diesem Moment Dinge zu tun geben, die wichtig sind, die man als Bürgermeister zu tun hat. Und man geht dann nicht Tennis spielen. Dann ist man im falschen Job. Und genau so war das ja auch bei Anne Spiegel. Wenn sie sagte, ich bin Mutter und wir waren überfordert und brauchen Urlaub. Schön und gut. Aber dann ist sie in diesem Moment nicht die Richtige im Job. Denn das muss sie hinten anstellen bei einer solchen Katastrophe, wie sie im Ahrtal war.
Ja, das finde ich auch sehr gut. Und wir kommen gleich auf dieses Thema. Also sozusagen, im Anschluss heute passen zwei Clips, die ich habe, beide dazu. Das Ding ist doch, wir sehen doch jetzt an vielerlei Stellen so eine Art sozio-logisches Display von Leistungs- und Publikumsrollen. Und wir alle haben vor Augen, wie Donald Trump da in Mar-a-Lago in diesem schwarz umhangenden, was auch immer, spontan errichteten Situation-Room sitzt. Und Peacat Hackthast neben ihm sitzt und es gerade noch schafft, am Computer x.com aufzurufen, in der Suchzeile Minizuela reinzuschreiben, um einfach zu gucken, wie die Weltöffentlichkeit darauf reagiert, auf den Content, den sie gerade hergestellt haben. So, mit diesem Content haben diese Leute nichts zu tun. Die haben einfach Befehle gegeben. Dann hat das Militär drei Tage lang gesagt, das Wetter passt gerade nicht. Und der Präsident sagt, da könnt ihr jetzt langsam mal. Und die so, nee, wir haben hier die Hoheit darüber und müssen unsere Soldaten beschützen. Das Wetter passt gerade nicht.
Trump hat wieder gesagt, wie im Fernsehen war es.
Genau, es war eine totale Unterordnung, diese Zuschauerschaft der totalen Leistungsrolle, nämlich Oberbefehlsgeber. Und so ist das auch in Berlin. Ich glaube einfach nicht dran, dass es irgendeine Aufgabe für Kai Wegner gab, die zu erfüllen ist. Wobei ich auch denke, die Bereitschaft ist dann das wichtige Signal. Man geht dann tatsächlich nicht händisch.
Mir geht es nicht darum zu sagen, der hat das ja, das Zepter in der Hand und der kann das alles managen.
Das Zepter ist schon genau das richtige Wort dafür.
Genau, das kann niemand glauben. Genauso auch bei Arne Spiegel kann das niemand glauben. Es geht aber auch nicht nur um ein Signal, sondern es geht schon darum, dass Arbeit zu tun ist. Also wenn sie nicht zu tun ist, dann brauchen wir diese ganzen alle nicht mehr.
Den Kai Wegner brauchst du, bis diese Katastrophe passiert. Danach ist hoffentlich alles in Place. Das ist die Aufgabe der Politik. Nicht plötzlich in die Leistungsrolle der Ausführenden.
Aber die Politik ist auch in einer Funktion zu entscheiden.
Ja, ich weiß, dass alle Leute so denken, weil genau ihnen das von den Tagesthemen und so reingeredet wird. Aber ich glaube, das Gefüge ist grundsätzlich anders.
Die Frage, die wir uns hier stellen, ist, kann Kai Wigner den Unterschied machen oder nicht? Und wir würden beide sagen, wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber es ist schon so, dass er mit seiner Arbeit auch beiträgt zu all dem Ganzen. Also am Ende kann ich auch sagen, ob der eine Feuerwehrmann jetzt da noch steht oder nicht, der hätte ja auch Tennis spielen gehen können. Nein, alle sind herangezogen. Genau. Und dann gilt das natürlich auch für den regierenden Bürgermeister.
Ja. So, jetzt zur komplexen Sache. Friedrich Merz, Völkerrecht, irgendwas passiert im Ausland. Er weiß auch nicht weiter.
Also wir sind jetzt schon wieder im Bereich der Regierungssimulation angekommen.
Wir sind thematisch wo ganz anders, aber bei demselben Problem. Die Spitzenleistungsrollen in der Politik stehen neben einem Geschehen und versuchen, uns zu erklären, was sie da anrichten. Denn ohne Frage, Friedrich Merz, ist in Mitverantwortung in so etwas passiert. Also wir wollen dann einfach hören und sei es auf einem Marktplatz gebrüllt, ob das jetzt okay ist, in den Irak zu ziehen und man die Spurenz hier nicht mitmacht. Oder eben damals war es ja nicht nur Gerhard Schröder, sondern es war ja auch Joschka Fischer, der eben gesagt hat, vor der UN, you have to make the case. Und wenn der Case nicht da ist, können wir leider die Spurenz hier nicht mitmachen. Und jetzt hat sich ja Merz einfach davor gedrückt und hat gesagt, ich sehe wohl, dass da was passiert, aber ich kann es noch nicht ganz deuten. Es ist sehr komplex.
Völkerrechtlich kompliziert.
Während ja Armin Laschet im Prinzip das Vorgehen Verteidigte von Trump, das ist ja ganz erstaunlich, dass er im Prinzip diese Schritte alle mitgehen würde.
Aber da sind wir ja schon in jemand hat sich halt positioniert und wir können es kritisieren, aber sich einfach daneben zu stellen, sagen, ich als Jurist, der sehr stolz darauf ist, Jurist zu sein, der sogar eine 20-jährige Politikpause für die Juristerei gemacht hat. Ich erkenne es gerade nicht so. Das ist ja schon eigene Qualität. Und witzig ist ja im Kontrast dazu, dass es, also wie wenig es komplex ist, dass nicht mal jemand eine Anstrengung übernimmt, um überhaupt eine Komplexität im Sinne von, es gibt auch noch eine Alternative herzustellen. And there is a very funny, also I laughed myself dead, I've seen it ten times yesterday, cut from Donald Trump in the Air Force One, who tries to explain something to the press. And next to him, Lindsay Graham tries to explain the same thing, but in the old fashion of the real thing. It's complex. We all know from the past, how it was. Ja, genau, wir wollen hier, da sind Massenverdichtungswaffen. Ja, also alles total kompliziert. Da brauchen wir jetzt militärische Spezialisten, die das machen. So und ich hab mich leider, dieser Clip ist drei Minuten 46. Ich wollte ihn nicht kürzen, weil John Stewart hat es so wunderbar umrahmt. Also wir nehmen uns jetzt wenige, also nur ein Clip, aber den mal ein bisschen länger vor, um einfach den Gegenpol zu, es ist wahnsinnig völkerrechtlich kompliziert und so zu machen. Und zwischendrin hört ihr dann Trump und Lindsey Graham. Also wunderbar eingefasst von John Stewart.
Generally, in American history, when we intervene in another country, whether true or not, we come up with a high-minded pretense. Liberating a people, spreading democracy, introducing baseball to the Japanese. They complained at first, but it was totally worth it. On what moral foundation will this conflict be framed?
We're going to have presence in Venezuela as it pertains to oil, but we're going to get the oil flowing the way it should be.
It seems a little on the nose. Um, oil, precious commodity, certainly. But not the reason a country formed 250 years ago on the ideas of liberty and self-determination would go into a country and snatch a man at night. There must be a slightly more noble pretense.
We're going to be taking out a tremendous amount of wealth out of the ground. We need total access.
Mach doch mal gerade Stop. Denn wir erinnern uns ja sehr gut an den Krieg im Irak. Als dann immer von linker Seite gesagt wurde, Da wurde Bush marschiert in den Irak ein wegen des Öls. Dann wurde immer von konservativer, transatlantischer Seite gesagt, nein, nein, es sind die Werte und seht doch hier, jetzt ist die Statue von Saddam Hussein gefallen. Das ist ein Tag der Freiheit. Also ich erinnere mich noch an Talkshows, als sei es gestern gewesen. Wer da so alles gesessen hat, inklusive Michel Friedmann und Helmut Karasek und alle waren begeistert davon, dass jetzt endlich dieses Volk befreit wurde. Dann wurde immer so von links gesagt, naja, es geht eigentlich um Geschäfte, um Öl und all das. Das Geschäft, am Ende können wir auch sagen, ist nicht besonders gut ausgegangen für die USA. Das war eher teuer. Und ein risikoreiches Investment, das Risiko hat sich nicht gelohnt. Aber das war eben der Diskurs, der aus so einer anti-imperialistischen Perspektive herauskam, dass man sagte, eigentlich mit so ein bisschen Lenin im Rücken, ja, das ist eben der imperiale Kapitalismus, der dort als kolonial herauftritt.
Der imperiale Imperativ. Das muss jetzt so sein. Die Leute, wir müssen hier Befreiung. Jetzt hat man hier schon Lindsey Graham gesehen. Jetzt hören wir ihn gleich.
Is this your first war?
I mean, what the f***?
Alright, let's table this for now. Senator Lindsey Graham, you're an old hand at warmongering. You're on the plane. Can you help this dude out with the Casas Belli and keep Trump from bringing it back to oil?
Genial.
Also, es ist eine wunderbare Szene.
Es ist einfach genial. Und jetzt steht ja der Handelsminister auch noch im Raum.
What? We can't even be conspiracy theorists now. I think they did it for the oil. Yeah, no, I did it for the oil. Is there any other reason? Can you give us anything? There's a lot of issues, human rights violations, political prisoners down in Venezuela. We could certainly free them and improve the lives of dissidents.
You're going to demand that Delcey Rodriguez let opposition figures return or free any political prisoners?
We haven't gotten to that yet. Right now, what we want to do is fix up the oil.
Have minerals, right, all the critical minerals. They have a great mining history that's gone rusty. So steel, aluminum, minerals.
These motherfuckers are going full Conquistador in front of our eyes. I mean, they got oil, steel, minerals. Oh, and don't forget about the spices. We'll load our ships with cinnamon and cardamom and oil and everything bagels. You'll see.
Also, wir brauchen auf gar keinen Fall ein Gedenken an Kolonialismus, weil das ist ja erstens ganz lange her und wir haben ja keine Städten dafür. Außer, dass das ganze Fernsehprogramm voll ist davor.
Ja, ja. Wolfram Weimar tut so, als sei der Kolonialismus so weit zurück, dass wir uns schon nicht mehr an ihn erinnern müssen. Dabei erleben wir ihn fortwährend. Es ist interessant, dass Leute wie Armin Laschet, und er ist ja wirklich nicht der Einzige, sondern es gibt ja einige, die das feiern oder auch im Springerhaus, ist man sowieso ganz begeistert jetzt von dieser Intervention, von diesem völkerrechtswidrigen Angriff. Anders kann man es ja nicht bezeichnen. Was wir dann erleben aber im deutschen Diskurs, ist, dass diese Leute immer noch versuchen, so hinzudrehen, dass es hier dann doch eigentlich um die Dissidenten und weiß ich nicht wen geht. Die könnte man ja tatsächlich als solche thematisieren. Die haben aber nie interessiert in den letzten Jahren. Nie hat sich irgendjemand diese Leute für Dissidenten in Venezuela interessiert. Aber jetzt kommen sie natürlich plötzlich damit an. Sie sind eigentlich noch nicht angekommen in diesem Zeitalter der neuen Ehrlichkeit, das ja hier ganz klar ausgerufen ist. Denn deutlicher kann man nicht werden. Die Altvorderen wie Lindsey Graham versuchen es nochmal nach der alten Art. Aber nein, Trump fährt eben über den Mund und sagt, nein, es geht hier ums Öl, ums Öl, ums Öl. Das ist die neue Ehrlichkeit, auf die man sich einstellen muss. Und da hilft das auch nicht, wenn man so noch von europäischer Seite, wie das ja auch Kaya Callas getan hat, ich war auch ganz entsetzt davon, so zu tun, als müsste man es doch nochmal schauen, wie man es bewertet. Sondern es ist ja von den Initiatoren schon gesagt worden, was die Intention ist. Da muss man ja sich nicht selbst fragen, finden wir nochmal eine neue Intention. Das ist aber etwas, was wir jetzt immer wieder erleben können, dass so im deutschen Diskurs oder auch im europäischen Diskurs Dinge wieder glatt gebügelt werden, obwohl es eigentlich schon... Also man legt nochmal ein Schleier drüber. Die ziehen selbst den Schleier runter und wir holen nochmal den Schleier raus. Und Kalas schaut nochmal, ob man doch nochmal so tun kann, als sei 2004.
Ja, also es ist wirklich ganz verrückt. Und dieses Wort Komplex hat ja ein Gegenwort. Und es ist eben nicht kompliziert und einfach, sondern es geht ja nicht... Merzer hat ja nicht gesagt, das ist Völkerrecht kompliziert. Sondern, also kompliziert ist es durchaus. Gibt's einen guten New York Times, The Daily Podcast dazu, wie hier Völkerrecht und indisches Recht. Und wie ist das jetzt, wenn amerikanische Soldaten im Ausland angegriffen werden, also offensiv wird geschossen, obwohl sie ja gerade invaden. Und wenn man dann zurückschießt, ist das durchaus als Selbstverteidigung. Aber nur nach amerikanischem Recht. Völkerrecht sagt dazu dann wieder gar nichts, weil ja schon vorher geklärt werden muss. Ist das dann ein illegaler Einmarsch? Und das ist auf jeden Fall, denn wir haben ja die Statuten. Entweder du wirst von der UN beauftragt, da einzufallen, oder das Land selber holt dich, und das ist beides nicht passiert. Und in der Ansicht ist es alles ganz klar. Und das Gegenwort von Komplex ist Komplett. Und mit Komplett ist eben gemeint, es gibt jetzt keine zweite Abzweigung, keine andere Möglichkeit der Deutung oder irgendetwas, sondern es ist eine komplette Geschichte. Die muss nicht gedeutet, die muss einfach nur gelesen. Und hier ist einfach, Amerika hat ein Interesse an Bodenschätzen. Und sie haben eine Macht, um sich diesen zu bereichern. Und eins plus eins ist zwei. Und da ist nichts kompliziert.
Sie hätten noch ein anderes Land gehabt, wo sie auch ähnliche Ölvorkommen haben, ähnliche Bodenschätze finden können. Das war Kanada. Das ist aber ein bisschen aufwendiger, wenn man da rein will. Insofern hat man sich für Venezuela entschieden.
Das kann man bei Spiegel Online und die großen Aufschlüsselungen sagen. Ja, das ist so viel Öl, dass es für Deutschland 500 Jahre reichen würde für die komplette Stromversorgung. Oder was man sonst noch mit Öl macht. Auf der anderen Seite ist das Öl nicht in so einem guten Zustand. Man hat es nicht mit so arabischem Öl zu tun, dass man einfach direkt verfeuern kann.
Man hat aber diese Raffinerien, die im Prinzip gerade leer stehen und die man jetzt da mit... Ja, aber das kostet viel Geld.... auf amerikanischem Boden, dass man das da macht. Was ja auch klimapolitisch eine interessante Perspektive ist, dass man hier also Öl für die Ewigkeit haben will. Das heißt, das ist ja nochmal ein ganz klarer Schritt dazu, dass wir uns vollkommen loslösen, zumindest hier in diesem politischen Westen, der ja auch dann noch von Deutschland und Europa mit unterstützt wird, von so etwas wie einer Politik gegen den Klimawandel. Denn das hier ist ja nun mit das Schlimmste über das Völkerrecht hinaus, das Schlimmste, was man gerade machen kann aus klimapolitischer Perspektive.
Und im Grunde, und wir haben ja das letzte Mal diesen von Milanovic, diesen Tenor mitgeliefert bekommen, wenn es mit dem Imperialismus nicht klappt, macht man Isolationismus. Und jetzt sieht das ja aus wie Imperialismus. Nur das, was hier stattfindet, ist ja auch das große Eingeständnis. Wir haben im Wettstreit mit China darum verloren, diese Energie einfach günstig und auch, sagen wir mal, zivilkompatibel herzustellen. Nur wir haben halt das Militär.
Das haben wir noch, ja.
Also nutzt man jetzt einfach das Militär.
Das ja jetzt nochmal verstärkt werden soll. Also es sind ja 500 Milliarden im Gespräch bei Trump jetzt. Bei China sind wir nochmal für das Militär. Es gibt Gerüchte, dass Trump jetzt nochmal viel mehr ausgeben will.
Also der Haushalt ist ja schon 800 Milliarden.
Ja, es ist ja interessant, wenn man sich die Militärausgaben insgesamt ansieht, ist man bei 2,7 Billionen und davon sind 37% an Militärausgaben bei den USA, 12% bei China. Und jetzt will Trump das nochmal stärker erhöhen, was deine These nochmal bestätigt, dass man sagt, wir haben schon mal die ganzen Stationen überall, so viele Militärbasen hat sonst niemand. Wir können da nochmal mit weiter kommen und folgen dann eigentlich so eine alten Frontier-These aus dem 19. Jahrhundert. Go West oder nach Venezuela oder sonst wohin, wo wir gerade dann einen Zugriff haben auf die Ressourcen, die wir benötigen. Und das ist die einzige Chance, weil man ja das andere abwickelt. Interessanterweise ist ja jetzt auch Elon Musk wieder an Trump herangerückt, obwohl er ja eigentlich sehen müsste, dass ja diese Ölgeschichte genau das ist, was er ja einst, wir haben es fast vergessen, vor 10, 12 Jahren, als ja auch aus der liberaldemokratischen Mitte viele Leute Elon Musk gut fanden, dass ja etwas war, was Elon Musk überwinden wollte, weshalb er Tesla so gegründet hat und auf die Elektromobilität gesetzt hat. Da kommt man gar nicht mehr so richtig zusammen.
Also wir sehen hier ganz viele Plan Bs einfach, weil Plan A's schon nicht mehr aufgehen. Aber die Plan Bs werden halt noch theatralisch auf der Vorderbühne ordentlich aufgeführt. Und es führt uns zu einem Thema, das auch mit dem Buch heute viel zu tun hat. Diese meritokratische Klasse, von der da geschrieben wird, die im Grunde eine alte Aristokratie, aber diesmal mit Know-how ist. Also Leute wissen dann wirklich, wie die Sachen funktionieren, statt einfach so Angestellte dafür zu haben.
Ja, also Leistung ist das Prinzip und nicht mehr Geburt.
Genau. Und da stellt sich einfach die Frage, wo bleibt denn jetzt der Show-Aspekt? Also die alte Aristokratie, wenn man sich Frankreich vor der französischen Revolution anschaut oder andere Beispiele in Europa, die man so hat, die sind ja nun, und darauf sind wir bis heute sehr stolz, von Herrlichkeit gezeigt. Und wie lässt sich das eigentlich noch retten, wenn einfach jeder direkt zeigen muss, dass er es wirklich kann? Also wenn gilt, wie eben schon gesagt, dass das Mitarbeiten in einer Bank, das Angestellten sein, lukrativer ist als das Besitzen. Da hat ja offenbar jemand jemanden gesagt, ich weiß hier Bescheid, ich kenne die Umsätze, ich hätte gern 80 Prozent davon. Und dann bleiben für den faulensten, den aristokratischen Eigner halt nur noch 20. So, das ist ja das Prinzip. Das heißt, wir haben eine Neuordnung von Show Aspect und Musikgang und eine Neu-Bedeutung von Industrie und echten Ackern. Und es gab einen Boxkampf. Du hast mir gerade auf dem Weg hierher gesagt, du hast davon nichts mitbekommen. Oder nur gehört, dass das gibt. Also auf Netflix kam letztes Jahr gegen Ende noch ein Boxkampf. Jake Paul gegen Anthony, Anthony, wer ist der denn? Joshua, entweder Joshua Anthony oder Anthony Joshua.
Ich habe nur damals den Boxkampf Jake Paul gegen Mike Tyson mitbekommen.
Den hat ja Jake Paul gewonnen. Was ihm einigen Nimbus gegeben hat, um zum Beispiel überhaupt so ein, wie Joe Rogan sagt, Knockout-Artist, wie Anthony, ich glaube, er heißt mit dem Nachnamen Anthony, aber es kann auch sein, dass Joshua der Name ist, wie auch immer.
Also ein Profi-Boxer in jedem Fall. Es ist ein Profi-Boxer.
Genau, nicht nur Profi-Boxer, sondern auch selber ein unglaubliches Show-Talent. Also man sieht ihn einfach auch gerne in Interviews oder so. Also ich habe das, als ich mir das so angeschaut habe, als ich den Boxer nicht gesehen habe, aber so im Nachgang, was das für ein Typ ist, habe ich gesagt, ja, macht was her. Und die beiden waren jetzt im Boxring und es stellt sich im Nachhinein heraus, Jake Paul hat diesmal verloren. Aber es gab wohl auf Polymarkets und so offensichtliche Wetten, die auch in die Richtung gingen, dass Jake Paul da eine Chance hätte. Und es stellt sich im Nachhinein heraus, never. Also der größte Fake ever wahrscheinlich, weil hier stehen einfach 160 Millionen Dollar Gage für die beiden. Also jeder 80 Millionen, unabhängig davon, wie der Kampf ausgeht. Einfach nur, weil Netflix Sendefläche hat. Nur die Sendefläche muss halt genutzt werden. Das heißt, wenn der Boxkampf ehrlich gewesen wäre, und das sagt eben, da gibt es jetzt auch Interviews mit Mike Tyson dazu, zehn Sekunden hätte man Jake Paul gegeben im Regen. Und da wäre das eigentlich gegessen gewesen. Ja, sonst wäre der KO gepissen. Genau. Soweit kommt man dann doch nicht, wenn man im Grunde tausend Videos macht mit Schabernack und nicht richtig Zeit fürs Training hat. Und wir gucken uns mal hier eine kurze Aufarbeitung an. Wir sehen es auch, aber es wird auch alles erklärt. Und dann können wir das nochmal besprechen. Und das zeigt ihm auch zu. Ja, ich habe das gesehen. Okay, ich mach jetzt mal locker.
Same strange tongue gesture. After that, Tyson backed off and stopped attacking. But recently, when Jake fought Anthony Joshua and made the same gesture, Anthony probably didn't understand his game and punched him so brutally that Jake's jaw was actually broken.
Also Jake, Paul wurde nicht nur einfach niedergeschlagen, sondern sein Gegner hat ihm auch noch mal zurück die Zunge rausgesteckt. Im Sinne von, ich sehe das schon, was du hier willst von mir. Aber wir sind hier gerade mit einem echten Boxkampf.
Alle Absprachen, die wir vorher getroffen haben, spielen jetzt keine Rolle.
Und es ist auch schon Runde fünf. Aber jetzt geht es um meinen Fame und ich lasse mich nicht vorführen wie Mike Tyson, der durchaus damals seine entsprechenden medialen hohen Momente hatte. Also in dem Sinne musste ein junger Mann natürlich jetzt einfach zeigen, wer hier der Herr im Ring ist. Und Jake Paul wurde so niedergeschlagen, dass er jetzt wirklich vier Titanenplatten hat und seine Zähne völlig derangiert, da neue gesortiert werden müssen und so. Also es ist einfach auch, wo man sich fragt so ein bisschen, was das jetzt wert hat. Hat das Spaß gemacht.
Jedenfalls, um das nochmal deutlich zu machen, es gab offenbar Absprachen zwischen Jake Paul und diesem Profiboxer, dass man sagte, wir bekommen hier zwischen Jake Paul und den bisherigen Boxern, nämlich alle, das ist jetzt eine Rückabwicklung dieser ganzen Geschichte, die dazu führte. Man macht also eine Show, bekommt, weil man Jake Paul ist und diese Leute heranziehen kann und bei Netflix ist, ein enormes Budget und sagt, lass uns das teilen, ich will auch gerne noch weiter kämpfen. Die nächsten drei Boxer sind schon fest in Aussicht. Ihr könnt mir jetzt hier nicht die Rübe zerstören, sondern wir müssen sehen, dass wir einigermaßen simulieren, dass es ein echter Kampf ist. Aber ihr dürft nicht so zuschlagen, wie ihr es eigentlich tätet, würdet ihr mit einem richtigen Boxer im Ring stehen.
So, wir sind also jetzt auf dieser Ebene angekommen, die es sonst nur in der Politik gab. Länder gehen Verträge miteinander ein und man fragt sich, vor welchem Gericht wollt ihr das jemals einklagen? Die gibt es ja gar nicht. Jake Paul wird auch ein Teufel tun, jetzt im Nachhinein eine Anklage zu formulieren mit, wir hatten doch eine Absprache und dann hast du mir trotzdem den Kiefer gebrochen, weil es geht ja gar nicht. Das wird auch für Jake Paul und diese ganze Internet-Gang, also nicht nur, weil sie von KI bedroht sind, dieses ganze Influenzertum, sondern auch wegen sowas, sie haben dafür eigentlich das Wrestling, nur es hat ihnen nicht gereicht. Sie wollten mehr Echtheit. Genau, und jetzt haben sie sich in Branchen eingemischt, wo es diese Gewinne, die sie glaubten machen zu können, nicht gibt. Und das wurde ihnen sehr brutal jetzt vor Augen geführt. Also dieses Ereignis finde ich, das ist ein bisschen wie der Gelsenkirchener Bankdiebstahl. Das wird zwar jetzt auch erstmal ein bisschen verschwinden und Jake Paul wird auch einen Teufel tun, das jetzt irgendwie selber groß aufzuklären. Aber die Interviewanfragen an Mike Tyson waren alle erfolgreich. Also der sagt offen, ja, meine Leute haben mich gefragt, wie hast du denn das gemacht? Ich habe mich auch geärgert darüber, das fürs Geld zu machen und so. Also die Aufklärung ist eindeutig. Wir haben es jetzt nicht mit einer komplexen völkerrechtlichen Lage zu tun. Ja, sondern es ist komplett. Hier geht es jetzt zur Sache. Und das finde ich, also 2026 hat einige Überraschungen im Petto, würde ich sagen.
Wir sprechen über ein Buch, das die These hat, dass wir eigentlich eine neue Aristokratie bekommen haben, die aber durch Leistung sich manifestiert. Eine neue herrschende Klasse, die superreich ist und sich von der Mittelklasse fundamental unterscheidet. Und wir lesen auch hier die Zahl, die wir bei Branko Milanovic schon vernommen haben. Nämlich diese Superreichen geben pro Kind 10 Millionen Dollar aus für Bildung, Erziehung, bis man dann groß ist und selbst dann zur meritokratischen Elite gehört. Im Vergleich zur Mittelklasse, was die an Budget zur Verfügung haben, beziehungsweise was an öffentlichen Geldern da sind. Das ist ein unglaubliches Buch mit wahnsinnigen Zahlen. Es ist ein Buch, das uns zeigt, eigentlich ist diese Idee der Leistungsgesellschaft, wir haben es schon bei Michael Sandel natürlich thematisiert, aber hier bekommen wir es nochmal ganz anders gerahmt, dass diese Idee der Leistungsgesellschaft eine enorm toxische ist, die eine Ungleichheit viel besser noch manifestieren kann, als das in der alten Aristokratie möglich war. Ich bin fasziniert von diesem Buch und habe dann aber zugleich schon etwas gefunden, was schon darüber wieder hinausgeht. Ich habe gerade die Zahl genannt. Zehn Millionen Dollar. Und daran kann man auch sehr gut sehen. Man kann offenbar aus einem Esel ein Rennpferd machen, wenn man nur genügend Geld reinsteckt. So funktioniert das. Und dann kommt eben das Kind auch nach Oxford, Yale oder wohin auch immer und wird dann nachher bei Goldman Sachs arbeiten. Und da könnte man ja noch einen Schritt weitergehen. Ich erinnerte mich, als ich das las, daran, dass Francis Fukuyama, der dieses Buch auch geschrieben hat, Das Ende des Menschen. Dort sagt er, was wäre, wenn es tatsächlich einmal möglich sein wird, Menschen zu züchten, die Sporen haben an den Füßen, mit denen sie die anderen treten wie Pferde. Damit wird gesagt, was ist, wenn man diese Klassenunterschiede noch mal biologisch festsetzen kann. Diese neue herrschende Klasse, die erleben wir jetzt, dass sie darüber genau sich Gedanken macht. Natürlich spielen da alle, schon erwähnten hier im Podcast, Alex K., Peter Thiel und so eine Rolle. Wir hören jetzt Alexander Wang. Der ist der Gründer von Scale AI. Das ist ein Unternehmen, das natürlich auch Geld bekommen hat von Peter Thiel. Da ist Mark Zuckerberg mit dabei. Amazon ist da mit drin. Die machen was eigentlich?
Also Scale AI wurde 2016 gegründet. Und es ist ganz interessant, weil sie ja auf einen Bedarf reagierten, den es gab, den wir heute erst richtig einschätzen können. Aber Amazon hat ja recht früh angefangen zu sagen, okay, wir haben hier so Datenmaterial, das muss mal aufbereitet werden, zum Beispiel CD-Cover. Und das Problem war, dieses CD-Cover hat man einfach als Bild bekommen, also millionenfach pro Jahr, je nachdem, wie viel Musik halt so publiziert wurde. Und Amazon musste das ja auf die Seite bringen. Man hat es ja nicht einfach ins Regal gestellt, im Sinne als Produkt, sondern da musste halt drunter stehen, was ist denn das eigentlich und wer singt denn da und so. Oder jetzt wie bei Spotify, dass die ganzen Liedtexte sekundengenau mitlaufen, wenn man eine Karaoke machen kann und so. Das sind also Datenaufbereitungen, die müssen erledigt werden. Das sind echte Aufgaben. Und man hatte dafür ganz lange keine Computer, aber halt den Bedarf. Weshalb Amazon angefangen hat, solche Sachen wie Mechanical Turk zu gründen. Man hat also selber Annotations oder wie es auch immer heißt, also diese Zuordnung von Daten und diese Datei sozusagen als Problem gehabt und hat das dann einfach ausgelagert in Klick-Workerei. Das heißt, in Bangladesch oder wo auch immer konnte man einfach seinen Computer anmachen, auf mechanicalturk.com gehen, dann waren wir bei Amazon auf der Seite und hatten einfach gesehen, ah, hier ist ein Task im Angebot. 100 CD-Cover und Lied-Texte matchen. Und dann hat Amazon geschrieben, das ist unsere 7,20 Euro wert und sehr viele Leute in Afrika und in Südasien, wo auch immer, haben gesagt, das ist eine gute Arbeit für mich. Also sitzen da hunderttausende vor Computern und klicken den ganzen Tag. Machen solche Minitas die ganze Zeit. Und Scale AI dachte sich, also wenn jetzt hier so ein Tee neu ist wie die bei Open AI sind schon recht weit und die brauchen jetzt hier solche Daten. Und zwar von allem was zur Verfügung steht, dann bieten wir das an. Also wir schaffen einfach Datengrundlagen, sortierte Daten.
Mit Click-Workern oder ohne?
Mit Click-Workern. Und das ist eben dieser Punkt. Scale AI, die uns heute dazu, dass Sam Altmann auf der Bühne stehen kann und sagen kann, das ist so faszinierend. Wir machen aus Sand Computerchips und in den Computerchips steckt Intelligenz. Also wir machen aus Sand Intelligenz. Die Grundlagenarbeit dafür ist menschliche Click-Workerei auf der ganzen Welt. Und dieses Business hat Scale AI angeboten. Also wir hören jetzt jemanden, der sozusagen die Spitze der Bürokratie formuliert, während er selber seine vielen Milliarden, die er verdient hat, einfach nur auf Ich biete jemanden die Click-Workerei-Jobs, die mir 20 Dollar im Monat auf der Seite sehen und verkaufe die dann als gesammelten Datensatz für Milliarden und Milliarden weiter. Das war im Grunde dieses Geschäftsmodell.
Alexander Wang, der jüngste Milliardär in der Geschichte offenbar, sagt jetzt Folgendes und das passt dann gut zu unserem meritokratischen Problem.
Basically, I want to wait to have kids until we figure out how Neuralink or other what's called brain computer interfaces or other ways for brains to interlink with a computer until they start working. So, there's a few reasons for this. First is...
Was wir also hier hören ist, die Kindererziehung kann man ja noch viel weiter treiben. Jetzt hat man zum Beispiel Vorschulen, wusste ich auch gar nicht, wie wichtig Vorschulen sind für die Elite, um die ganzen Talente zu fördern oder überhaupt erst zu entdecken bei den Kindern, wie viele Tausende man da schon für ausgibt. Aber wenn man es doch schon vor Geburt ein bisschen managen kann, beziehungsweise gleich nach der Geburt, also erstmal kann man natürlich mit Genpool und so weiter arbeiten, sind hier auch alle dran, aus so einem transhumanistischen Interesse heraus. Und dann könnte man doch mit Neuralink von Elon Musk oder anderem ein Update gleich im frühen Kindesalter verschaffen, weil da das Gehirn noch so flexibel ist.
Genau, wir haben ja den Text gelesen aus China, wie es damit der Genetik vor sich geht. Die sehen sich natürlich auch in so einem obskuren Systemstreit. Sie wissen nicht genau, welche nächste Kindergeneration aus China kommt und wollen halt mithalten.
In your first like seven years of life, your brain is more neuroplastic than at any other point in your life, like by an order of magnitude. I think when we get Neuralink and we get these other technologies, kids who are born with them are gonna learn how to use them in like crazy, crazy ways. Like it will be actually like a part of their brain in a way that it'll never be true for an adult who gets like a Neuralink or whatever hooked into their brain.
Das sind ja bisweilen dieselben Leute. Ist auch so eine typische Podcastsituation, wie man sie da kennt. Die Männer sitzen im dunklen Raum und haben eine komische Beleuchtung. Dort wird sich normalerweise darüber unterhalten, dass die ganzen Gender-Ideologen mit ihrer Frühsexualisierung der Kinder die ganzen Kinder kaputt machen und zerstören. Wir müssen die Kinder so aufwachsen lassen. Und die dürfen gar nicht in irgendeiner Weise in Berührung kommen mit der Erwachsenenwelt. Und hier wird einfach schon mal darüber spekuliert, was könnte man denen alles für Chips einsetzen in die Köpfe, damit es dann entsprechend funktioniert, wie wir uns das vorstellen.
And humans, we're only evolving at a certain rate. Humans will get smarter over time. It's just on the time scale of like millions of years because natural selection and evolution is really slow. So if you play this forward, right, like you're going to have AIs that are going to continue getting smarter, continue improving, like they're going to keep improving really quickly. And you know, biology is going to improve only so fast. And so what we need at some point is the ability to tap into AI ourselves. And so eventually, I think we're going to need some interlink or hookup between our brains directly to AI and the Internet and all these things. And it is potentially dangerous and it's potentially, you know, to your point, terrifying and scary. But we just are going to have to do it. Like, AI is going to go like this. Humans are going to improve at a much slower rate and we're going to need to hook into that capability. I've talked to a lot of scientists in this space and a lot of people working on this stuff, including the folks at Neuralink. And mind reading and mind control are like, those are the, that is where the technology will go over time, right? And so, like any advanced technology, we have to not fuck that up. But it's going to be pretty critical if we want, if we want humans to remain relevant as a...
Ja, also wir hören ja beide den Doppelgänger Podcast, weil der ist ja sehr gut. Und da wird der über, also da werden ja diese Schicksale ein bisschen eher begleitet. Und seine neuste Karrierestufe ist ja Chef für KI-Sachen bei Meta zu sein. Max Zuckerberg war also sehr unzufrieden mit der Ausbeute seiner Leute des größten Chipskaufs aller Zeiten. Also niemand hat so viel Nvidia-Kram gekauft wie Max Zuckerberg. Und am Ende kommt im Grunde nicht das bei Rom, was er wollte. Und da es nur wenige Leute gibt, die sich damit auskennen, hat er einfach Alexander Wang. Nur Alexander Wang ist halt ein Neokolonialist, der einfach die halbe Welt ausgebeutet hat mit Clickworkerei. Der hat auch keine richtige Ahnung. Klar kann man mal eine Mathe-Olympiade gewinnen und so, aber der Tenor bringt jetzt nicht das mit, was man da braucht. Was bedeutet, er sitzt da zwar mit Milliarden unterfüttert in so einer Bar und redet so darüber.
Ist aber eigentlich mit Dropshipping reich geworden, könnte man sagen. Da irgendwo wird die Arbeit getan, und dann nimmt man diese billigen Produkte und verkauft sie an Silicon Valley teurer.
Genau, ist ein ganz billiges Abitrage-Geschäft, was ihn so super reich gemacht hat, halt zur richtigen Zeit. Aber er hat im Grunde jetzt auch nicht mehr Ahnung als wir.
Ja.
Und die Leute, die davon Ahnung haben, also Sutzkäffer, Brockman, dieser Deepmind-Typ, der jetzt bei Google sogar Nobelpreise dafür kriegt, die stehen zwar alle auf der Bühne und erzählen auch von großen Potenzialen, aber sie bleiben eben bei diesem Grundbegriff Potenzial und sagen im Grunde, man muss mal schauen, so richtig verstehen wir es auch noch nicht, wir machen hier auch sehr viel Forensik und dann kann man halt bei Anthropic so den letzten Stand der Forschung einfach veröffentlicht lesen. Und da käme niemand auf die Idee, zu sagen, ja, ich warte jetzt noch kurz und es ist ja bei ihm auch jetzt sagen wir mal einen Zehn-Jahres-Zeitraum.
Ja, er ist jetzt neunundzwanzig und will noch ein paar Jahre warten, bis die Kinder kommen dürfen.
Genau, indem er erwartet, dass jetzt irgendwie so in sechs Jahren, während du ja zu Recht immer sagst, naja, das ist selbst mit dem selbstfahrenden Auto ist schwierig so. Und er erwartet jetzt einfach, dass das Gehirninterface fertig ist in den nächsten zehn Jahren. Also ist ja absurd.
Die Sache ist nur, sie würden es tun, wenn es ginge. Und das ist das Bemerkenswerte jetzt hier, dass wir da eine völlige Loslösung haben von zum Beispiel einer christlichen Schöpfungsidee oder so, sondern dass die jetzt wirklich sagen, wir müssen den Supermenschen basteln, damit er im Konkurrenzkampf gegen China bestehen kann, gegen AGI auch noch in irgendeiner Weise eine Relevanz hat. Das heißt, wir haben es schon mit einer neuen Elite zu tun, die eigentlich sicher bei sehend einen neuen Menschen zu schaffen.
Ja, aber hier wird es ja jetzt soziologisch, politisch und zivilgesellschaftlich wahnsinnig interessant, denn was macht diese Meritokratie, die der Daniel Markowitz beschreibt, eigentlich so zu kräftig? Das sind die Grundbegriffe fleiß zum Beispiel und diese Ansage, jeder kann es schaffen, weil es kann ja jeder einfach 100 Bücher pro Jahr lesen und 80 Stunden die Woche arbeiten und so. Kann ja prinzipiell jeder. Wenn allerdings die erste Generation mit so einem Chip im Kopf auftaucht, dann ist genau diese Erzählung nichts mehr wert.
Ja.
So, das heißt, die größte Ausbeutergeschichte, nämlich dass die meritokratische Klasse sich selber ausbeutet, durch diesen enormen Bildungsweg und dann 80 Wochenstunden arbeiten. Und diese Ausbeutung wirklich nur gemacht wird. Und die sagen selber alle, ja, ja, das sind schon Bullshit-Jobs. Und dann stellt er ja, also er ist Law-Professor in Yale und stellt seinen Studenten die Frage, wenn ich euch 15 Stunden die Woche Arbeit gebe, die völlig sinnlos ist und ihr wisst es auch, aber ihr kriegt dadurch mehr Punkte auf dem Zeugnis, würdet ihr es machen? Und alle sagen ja.
Und können auch die Frage gar nicht verstehen, warum das ein Problem sei.
Dann stellt sich ja da, sie wollen diesen Fleiß ausbeuten und damit zeigen, dass sie exzeptionell sind. Nur wenn sie diese Klammer zu den 99 Prozent der Rest nicht machen können, also wenn die Botschaft nicht mehr ist, ihr könntet ja auch, ihr müsst nur an der Schule richtig aufpassen, sondern es einfach Startvoraussetzungen gibt, die anders sind, dann haben wir es ja mit einer materiellen Neu-Diskussion zu tun. Also in der ganz viel Ideologie nicht mehr funktionieren.
Die es ja schon gibt, dadurch, dass sie das Kapital haben, dass ihnen das ermöglicht, das so zu machen und die besten Lehrer und all das so haben.
Und darüber läuft ja auch der Ungerechtigkeitsdiskurs.
Ja, und jetzt können wir ja noch, der nächste Schritt wäre dann, dieses Update sich zu verschaffen und dann kann man natürlich gewisse Erzählungen nicht mehr reproduzieren, aber Markowitz schreibt ja auch, es gibt gerade bei den Erfolgreichsten die größte Angst abzurutschen und wenn man dies vermeiden könnte dadurch, dass man es grundsätzlich einprogrammiert, dass da nichts mehr ist, ja man programmiert sich den Erfolg ein durch diesen Chip, dann wäre das für die eigentlich die Rettung, um endlich ihre Abstiegsangst loszuwerden. Das ist der Punkt, glaube ich, der hier so stark verfolgt wird, denn alles läuft ja auf so eine Aristokratie hinaus.
Die zweite Dimension ist aber, dass die restliche Bevölkerung mitmacht. Und das wäre dann anders zu... Also das muss anders hergestellt werden. Weil dann kannst du nicht mal sagen, wir sind doch alle in die Schule gegangen.
Nein, das dann nicht.
Von daher, das sind schon Herausforderungen, die er natürlich nicht sieht und so. Also wir haben hier jemanden, der was gesagt hat.
Wir haben es jedenfalls mit einem sehr bemerkenswerten Buch zu tun. Wir werden darüber jetzt gleich ausführlich diskutieren. Ich will einen Begriff schon mitbringen hier vor den Salon, nämlich den Begriff Exzellente Schafe, so bezeichnet werden ja diese neuen meritokratischen Eliten beschrieben. Das heißt, sie sind clever und sie haben alle Skills, alle Zertifikate, aber sind exzellente Schafe. Das heißt, sie machen alles mit und beuten sich dabei selbst aus. Es ist wirklich ein Buch, das uns vieles anders sehen lässt. Denn wir haben ja hier einen sehr starken Diskurs darüber, dass ja sehr viele Leute so ein Leistungsdosis-Einkommen beziehen durch Mieten etc. Aber es gibt eben auch das hier, dieser Fall. Und zwar, dass man über das Einkommen so immens reich wird. Und in den USA ist das, auch das müssen wir nachher besprechen, viel stärker als in Deutschland. Aber wir sehen auch in Deutschland, wohin sich das bewegt, wenn wir uns den Genicoeffizienten dann genauer ansehen. Jedenfalls ist das das Buch über das wir sprechen, The Meritocracy Trap von Daniel Markowitz. Ein wirklich sehr interessantes Buch, über das wir im Salon diskutieren. Außerdem gibt es noch Empfehlungen von uns. Einmal Musik, Heidel, Streichquartett. Dann habe ich von der Essaystin und Künstlerin Hito Steyerl ein Buch über KI und Bildgenerierung gelesen. Eine Erzählung bringe ich mit von Ben Shattuck. Die Geschichte des Klangs, die bald verfilmt wird oder schon verfilmt ist mit Joshua Conner und Paul Maskell. Außerdem blicken wir kurz auf die katholische Kirche. Wie steht die eigentlich zur Aufrüstung? Und da ist es auch nicht so viel besser. Und wir üben uns an einer Kritik am Bundesverfassungsgericht, das ja hier im Podcast immer sehr hochgehalten wird. Aber vielleicht ist es ein Problem, wenn man nur juristische Argumente gelten lässt, sagt zumindest der Rechtswissenschaftler Uwe Volkmann in der FAZ.
Gut, ich für meinen Teil bringe mit ungleichheit.info. Wir lesen heute mal eine Webseite, denn Martina Linatas Buch, das ja im April kam, Unverdiente Ungleichheit, oder wie es heißt, haben wir ja verpasst. Unverdiente Ungleichheit. Wie der Weg aus der Erbengesellschaft gelingen kann, ist ja sowieso, jetzt wollen wir mal kurz lesen, wo wir heute das Lesen noch mal anders zu deuten so. Aber diese Webseite ist ganz interessant. Und ich bin auch total dafür, dass wir Webseiten grundsätzlich ein bisschen mehr würdigen. Wir betonen ja immer, dass unser Podcast eine Webseite hat. Ich sehe häufiger Podcasts, die keine eigene Webseite haben. Also schlage ich mich auf Seiten des Silicon Valley oder bei Spotify rum und finde Informationen nicht, die ich eigentlich mal bräuchte und so.
Brauchen wir also für Wohlstand für alle auch eine eigene Webseite?
Unbedingt. Ich finde, jede Person braucht eine eigene Webseite.
Ja, ich habe eine Webseite.
Ja, aber wir hauchen den Webseiten auch noch mal ein bisschen Lebendigkeit ein demnächst. Ich will heute schon anmerken, wir haben Ergänzungen. Dieser Podcast heute bekommt auch einen eigenen Diskurskanal. Das ist also die Standardangelegenheit für semiöffentliche Diskurse, also vor allem Podcast-Rückmeldungen, die man anders als Discord und der ganze Müll, den wir wirklich kaum zu benutzen, einfach selbst hosten. Also smalltalk.neuezwanziger.de, aber es ist auch in den Shownotes. Kann man natürlich weiter E-Mails schreiben an uns, aber bei vielen E-Mails denke ich mir, die sind so gut und lehrreich, die könnte man eigentlich auch mal so semiöffentlich zur Verfügung stellen. Also vielleicht kann man seine E-Mail einfach benutzen, seine E-Mail-Adresse, um sich bei diesem Smalltalk anzumelden, beziehungsweise anmelden, man sagt einfach hier, das bin ich, dann kommt man eine E-Mail und dann ist man authentifiziert und schreibt einfach sein Kram. Also das seht ihr dann, das ist sehr easy. Also Ungleichheit gehen wir einmal durch, und zwar wie es im Internet dargestellt wird. Dann ein Text, der wirklich schockierend ist. Die Ukraine ist in schwierigen Fahrwasser und es gibt einen Ausweg, und zwar fällt der Silicon Valley da gerade ein, um semi-autonome Drohnen herzustellen. Und wir können nachher mal, wenn ich den Text vorstelle, überlegen, wo sind hier noch Unterschiede zu solchen Büchern wie David Suarez's Kill Decision, wo es einfach um kleine Schwärme geht, die vor zehn Jahren schon in der Literatur losgeschickt wurden. Also da hat auch Eric Schmidt von Google einiges getan, damit da einfach keine Lücke mehr ist zwischen Realität und Alterfiktion. Außerdem zwei Texte zur KI. Das eine ist den letzten Monat schon angekündigten, den wir heute mal besprechen. LLM und das M steht für Mistake. Large Language Mistake, glaube ich. Ja, genau. Das ist also ein Text aus einer aktivistischen Richtung, der sich mit der Frage beschäftigt, Denkenmaschinen eigentlich oder ist es wirklich nur Simulation von Sprache? Also steckt was dahinter? Während wir für uns denken, na ja, auch wenn ich gerade nichts sage, denke ich ja. Und da steckt eine Qualität drin. Und das konfrontieren wir mal mit einem zweiten Text. Und der hat die Fragestellung, Was wäre, wenn die Leser KI-Texte lieber mögen? Das ist hochinteressant von Vohini, die ich nicht kannte, aber jetzt sehr schätze, Vara, eine Autorin, die sowohl in diesem journalistischen Tech-Bereich, als auch in der Roman-Produktion zu Hause ist und im New Yorker einen wirklich sehr langen Text geschrieben hat über diese Fragestellung mit einem ganz einfachen Szenario. Das will ich schon mal vorstellen. Du sitzt als Nobelpreislitteraturträger an deinem Schreibtisch und erlebst eine Schreibblockade, weil du darüber schreiben möchtest, wie deine Mutter erlebte, dass dein Bruder zwei Stunden nach Geburt starb. Also sie trauert und du gehörst zu dieser Familie. Und Leute, die diesen Text später lesen, wissen auch, das ist ziemlich authentisch, weil hier schreibt der Bruder über klar, es ist ein Roman, aber es ist sozusagen nah dran. Und dir wollen aber partout nicht die richtigen Worte dafür einfallen, wie diese Mutter trauert. Also du hast eine ganz spezifische Fragestellung. Und welchen Weg gibt es der KI zu sagen, mach mir Entwürfe für dieses Szenario, also einfach nur für die nächsten drei Sätze in meinem großen Roman. Und dann findest du einen Modus, in der die KI das macht. Und zwar so, dass du feststellst, ich kann es nicht übertrumpfen. Und die Testleser, die ich habe, loben mich dafür, was ich da wieder hingezaubert habe. Und man selber verzweifelt daran, dass man es nicht besser ausdrücken kann, als es die KI gerade gemacht hat. Und diesen Modus hat ein Professor wohlgefunden. Und sie schreibt darüber. Es ist auch, finde ich, ein richtiger New Yorker Text. Also das Magazin, ich habe letztens diese Doku gesehen auf Netflix, sehr beeindruckend, die seit 100 Jahren diese Zeitung machen. Und ja, da geht es ans Eingemachte. Da sag ich, gut, wir hören die Wortlaute nachher. Ich hab sie von KI einlesen lassen. Also wir können wirklich überprüfen, was hier Sachlage ist.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Haben wir heute zweimal Literatur im Salon. Den Salon kann man abonnieren und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr das tut. Man kann ihn auch verschenken. Auch das ist möglich. Man kann ihn auch für sich abonnieren. Das geht über Apple ganz einfach mit einem Klick. Das ist aber auch möglich, wenn man bei Patreon schon angemeldet ist oder man geht, und das präferieren wir, zu Steady bzw. geht auf neuezwanziger.de, dann wird man direkt zu Steady geführt und kann dort den Salon abonnieren. Wir empfehlen eine Jahresmitgliedschaft. Das ist dann im Ganzen günstiger. Und man kann natürlich auch, sobald man den Salon abonniert hat, ob für das ganze Jahr oder für einen Monat, kann man alle alten Folgen dann hören. Auch die Live-Salons, zu den Live-Salons. Wir werden jetzt auch gleich im Salon nochmal die Termine bekannt geben.
Wollen wir sie nicht direkt einfach auf die Webseite stellen?
Sollen wir sie jetzt öffentlich machen?
Ja, ich denke, es hatten jetzt alle die Chance. Wir sagen sie doch nicht nochmal an, sondern auf der Webseite sind jetzt einfach diese vier Termine notiert. Spätestens morgen, für den Fall, dass ich den Podcast heute schon veröffentliche, aber erst morgen im Zug, wenn ich nach Nürnberg fahre und erlang, ich hoffe, das klappt irgendwie, der Wetterlage, aber ich, also wenn der Zug steht, aber ich Internet habe und heute es nicht mehr schaffe, die Termine werden jetzt die nächsten Tage auf der Webseite stehen. Die haben dann einen einzelnen Link jeweils. Man muss also nicht mal in die Case eine E-Mail schreiben, sondern die Case hat sich jetzt auch geupgradet.
Ja.
Und dann kann man einfach buchen.
Wunderbar. Dann sehen wir uns gleich im Salon.
Bis gleich.